vamos a dividir 7.182 entre 42 y lo
diferente en este ejemplo es que ahora
estamos dividiendo por un número de dos
dígitos no uno de un dígito sino de dos
esto es un poco más aterrador se puede
decir aunque es la misma idea
cuántas veces cabe 42 en 7 ninguna pero
cuántas veces cabe en 71 una vez
entonces lo que está pasando aquí
estamos diciendo que 42 cabe en 7 mil
182 100 veces pero vamos a enfocarnos en
el proceso 1 por 42 eso es 42 entonces
71 menos 42 tal vez puedas hacerlo en la
cabeza en tu cabeza puedes hacer la
resta sabes que 72 menos 42 es igual a
30 entonces 71 menos 42 es igual a 29
algo bueno yo así lo pienso o puedes
hacerlo de la manera usual queremos
restar el 2 del 1 no se puede entonces
pedimos prestado al 7 y nos va a quedar
y de este lado esto se convierte en un
11 así que 11 menos 29 64 eso es 2 y nos
queda 29 ahora bajamos este 8 para abajo
entonces aquí sucede lo artístico porque
estamos dividiendo por un número de dos
dígitos ajá tenemos que estimar cuántas
veces 42 cabe en 298 échale un vistazo
si te equivocas no pasa nada lo vuelves
a hacer no no pasa nada por ejemplo para
saber que te equivocaste tú dices ok
vamos a intentarlo con 9 y lo intenta si
multiplicas 9 por 42 si el resultado es
mayor a 298 entonces lo intentas con un
número menor a 9 si dices que es por
ejemplo 3 entonces 3 por 42 si el
resultado es al restarlo con 298 si es
mayor a 42 entonces también cometiste un
error esto según yo es más o menos 7 a
lo que yo calculo vamos a intentarlo
veamos 7 por 2 es igual a 14
7 x 4 es 28 más uno es igual a 29
entonces 294 nos acercamos bastante
debes notar que 298 es un poco mayor a
294 estamos bien ahí y también mi
residuo es menos que 42 vamos muy bien
bajamos este 2 y ahora nos preguntamos
cuántas veces cabe 42 52 42 caben 42
exactamente una vez 1 por 42 es igual a
42 restamos si no tenemos residuo por lo
tanto se dividió exacto es exacto 7.182
dividido entre 4 es exactamente 171